I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I would love to get back to
tipping consuming is one of those things
that I think is you know it's a
polarizing subject I'm a huge tipper and
I don't want to mean that I have a
reputation as you should I come up about
$100 bills which is kind of like the old
Hollywood you know hundreds at a strip
bar thing that's not what I mean what I
mean is like I love service and when
service is caring when they're when
they're helping that me they're
successful it could be a bad interaction
with what you're doing and yeah but the
service is great yeah yeah I get person
on the phone helped you and it's a-you
know about an airline it's not their
fault that the airline screw you up yeah
and if they really help they did
everything they could
well then I either write a letter or if
it's in person I tip because I believe
in that I do it mostly for myself it
makes me feel good it's like you know
what I know where they're at I know what
they make I know that this is gonna help
them and I I don't tip I over tip and I
it's not because I would tip just
because I want to and I don't over tip
everybody if I don't get good service I
won't I'll tip but I'm like okay that
was not pleasant you know so I believe
in that I think it's a real important
thing to do is to really someone once
that every interaction you have with
someone anyone even the people you don't
like be just a little bit kinder than
you have to be and the world will be so
much better and I really believe that
just a little bit kind some people make
it so hard that not all they do
I totally agree with you probably you
never know what they're struggling with
you know I heard a story the other day
it was something about a kids are out of
control and says I you know something
about you know saying to the dad like
get your kids out of control and under
control and it was like we just you know
my wife just died yesterday or something
oh we're doing our best and you're like
oh god and you're just like you never
know what someone is dealing with so I
have a hard time I mean it's something I
struggle with to give people the benefit
of the doubt that they're doing their
best but that is that is like a mantra I
try and remember is everybody's doing
their best and they're also they're also
only able to do their best from their
own level of consciousness correct and I
always learn you I've learned over the
last
I would say 15 years maybe 20 years is I
always when someone's quiet and not say
anything that looking me in the eye or
there's a problem or they're a little
scruff or scruff I
I saw the deliverer reverse-psychology
I'm like hi what's your name so I love
what you're wearing is something I just
make a compliment thank the ice even if
it's not even a cop that you know like I
love those glasses or whatever and oh
thank you thank you I would you get him
and I know enough about stuff I could
say those that and all of a sudden the
person was like moody and quiet and
maybe feels bad for theirselves cuz
they're in the job they really don't
respect and they're like you know
sweeping a floor or like their PA and
they're not like happy they light up
yeah they light up and I never not and
never it doesn't happen never kindness
is always welcome it's just paying
attention to someone and really looking
in their eye and ask them a question and
then when they respond like come back
and like having something else to say
not just ice not just though and I drop
in a bomb on them mm-hmm and then all of
a sudden that person who's the shy
person in the corner is like okay he
started to talk to you and then on the
way out it's a different person
you're like either hi are you great
great to see you nice meeting you so
nice to chat with you and when you came
in you have it you have this judgment of
people you know that person looks
miserable oh my god you know stay away
from me oh yeah it's easy to do because
it's natural it's what we do
you know we judge everything every day
so that's something I've learned I was
never really good at it and I've gotten
much better I can't say I'm perfect at
it but I can see I can spot it it's a
wonderful how immediately
you